I came to this video kitsune God but
kitsune gari kitsune Gary from the US
snow name in them but a funny picture of
a cat with some hood on it okay so on we
have a yeah let's see modern it could
still be Kings Indian will see form
maybe on c4 let's let's play something
else that's let's let's stay within the
territory offering modern defense this
is some quite interesting this way of
fun playing
try it for an early pressure against
your phone there should be two now some
normal there should be two maybe this
should be to bishop at xf3 Bishop takes
f-35 and let's not spend too much time
try to be on ahead on the clock for once
let's enter here y term probably should
play an F form and the near future try
to undermine the night but okay b2b need
to be a well timed yes this is so
awesome nie diem I was just thinking
about this month it wasn't too sure how
to react to that
okay let's just capture of course the
sum is problematic on the Queen a phone
no not really right okay the C file is
of course a problem but I thought that I
have not aged 52 form yes I know but I
thought I could maybe just give it away
play Queen f6 Queen takes Queen f6 night
afore this kind of ideas for once I want
to want to be had on the clock come on
let's just play quickly him this is
probably unsound but I lost so many
games well I hope ponents played
completely unsound nonsense I I can do
that for once for once myself okay 92
was the idea
now okay it is probably a really happen
sound for black but okay what did it has
this position I have got the farm more
secure King this is cecilia his king is
always a liability him and yeah yeah I'm
maybe maybe getting somewhere here let's
let's see is there some way to explore
the fatigue to know
93 and I can take h6 all the time the
Sun this is a bit a bit annoying
greenage fry can take it form and this
shouldn't be enough
mmm yeah did this hanging bishop
ok let's let's do that if he goes Queen
a7 I just go okay I take a to this is ok
and now the queen is even more side
I don't have look cierto ever okay let's
do that there are there is play on the
dark squares no no doubt about that I
can always go Queen h3g too and so I can
I can harass through p.m. and wow this
is this is ambitious probably probably
ok but ambitious
check
I can play book see ATM yeah and I
should really I must play I was use the
C file if I can use the C fine here then
it is a really check I don't know around
here um I Roxy six I can play Roxy six
Roxy six and that's it quite easy a
proxy six wins wins almost for what if I
don't have anything on the sea far then
I don't have Oh
I forgot about this okay so I missed I
must oops Jack let's play like that and
now is there something better probably
not yeah what he what he played he is
probably not bad at all it's just it's
just very complicated um I think that I
was simpler ways to play just Rock c6
was some was quite good I'm hoping for
that him jack yeah of course I very
stupid it's just over he just marches
much as the a porn hey yeah he's got a 8
Queen and over black resigns yeah this
wasn't working with oxy 80 k then all
this was not since I need to go Queen g2
and try to get something them it's
probably just unsound I don't really
have something on the sea far the
easiest here Bishop f1 was was good I
mean very good I just thought you'd be
place that and I don't
any play at all but Bishop f1 was even
better just forcing the issue check and
this is just just just gone I mean I
lose this pawn and then the 8th porn
just masters marches down the board yeah
just an unsold attack it wasn't working
ok thanks for watching